10.000 kilometer langer bogen wolken
bogen auf der venus jetzt in science
fiction die venus atmosphäre ist 90 mal
so dicht wie die unserer erde
bei einer so dichten atmosphäre von
kohlenstoffdioxid mit schwefelsäure
wolken und immer mindestens 440 grad ist
es so gut wie unmöglich sondern heil auf
die oberfläche der venus zu bringen dort
irgendwelche forschung zu machen die
meisten kunden sind ganz einfach
zerbrochen
von weitem konnte man jetzt aber neue
aufnahmen der venus machen die
japanische venus sonde akatsuki
entdeckte dabei eine äußerst
ungewöhnliche folgen struktur zitat die
bogenförmige struktur reicht von der
nordpolarregion über den äquator bis in
die südpolregion von einem ende zum
anderen ist dieser bogen länger als
10.000 kilometer so tetsuya fukuhara von
der regio universität in tokio
neben der ungewöhnlichen größe des
bogens fällt auch die bewegungslosigkeit
völlig aus dem rahmen des normalen
frühere forschungsarbeiten sprechen
nämlich vom windstärken bis zu 100
metern pro sekunde auf der venus
der jetzt entdeckte wolken bogen blieb
aber ganze vier tage an ort und stelle
wie kann so etwas gehen wie die forscher
im fachmagazin nature geoscience
berichten könnte die unebene oberfläche
besondere gebirge für eine solche luft
bewegung sorgen
zitat die konvektion in den statischen
schichten zwischen den unteren wolken
und der oberfläche verhindert
normalerweise die ausbreitung der
schwere wenn wir vermuten daher dass die
winde in der niedrigeren atmosphäre
räumlich oder zeitlich variabler sind
als man bisher angenommen hat zitat ende
was meint ihr wetter ist ziemlich das
komplizierteste themengebiet dass es
überhaupt gibt ich hab das mag mich
damit beschäftigt brummt an der schädel
nach manier wasser auf der venus
passiert um keine news hier auf
kriegsfuß erwarten abonniert und dafür
hier kostenlos erwartungen und dann
sehen wir morgen wieder ach ja daumen
nach oben will auch klassik bis dann
bekannt